-It is time to play the
game that's sweeping the nation.
It's "Is There a 'Stache
Under That Mask?"
-"Is There a 'Stache
-This is a game where we pick
a random audience member
and guess if there is
a 'stache under their mask.
So, please welcome tonight's
audience member, Sharif Hessen.
Sharif?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome.
-Hey.
-Thank you for being here.
-How's it going?
Thanks for having me.
-Please, have a seat there.
Now, am I saying it right?
Is it Sharif? Sharif?
-Sharif.
Alright, Sharif Hessen.
Where are you from?
-I'm from Edison, New Jersey.
-Edison, New Jersey.
Now, that is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is all I can ask you.
Now we have to figure out
if you have a
'stache under that mask.
Quest, you go first.
One question for Sharif.
-Sharif, at Starbucks,
would you order hot chocolate
with whipped cream?
-Um...I don't order hot
chocolate.
-Wow!
-There's that.
-"There's that."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"There's that."
Quest, what's your guess?
-I don't think he has a 'stache.
-I got you. Okay.
[ Both chuckle ]
Tariq, your turn.
What's your question?
-If you were planning to
observe Movember,
would that involve much of
a transformation of
your upper lip?
-Hmm.
Remind -- What's Movember?
-Movember is when you spend the
month of November not shaving.
So you grow
your facial hair out.
-Okay.
-Why isn't it like Novem-beard?
-Look, listen.
Let's focus, Sharif.
-Yes, let's focus.
-So, do I -- I guess I prepare,
like, mentally, you know.
-This is a
"yes"-or-"no" question.
If you observe Movember --
-He answered you.
Tariq, there's your answer.
-No, no, no. I do not accept.
If you observe Movember,
which means you're
going to grow
your facial hair out --
-He's pressuring you.
You already answered.
You're fine.
-You don't shave for a month.
Would your --
-Can we turn
his microphone off, please?
-Do you use power tools, Sharif?
-Your honor, your honor!
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think he has a mustache.
-What do you think?
-I think he has
a mustache, Jimmy.
-Okay.
-Huh.
-I'm sitting
pretty close to you.
-Yeah.
-I'm looking at the mask.
You have a good head of hair.
-Thanks.
-And you have decent eyebrows.
-Do the curtains match
the drapes, Sharif?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Suspenseful music playing ]
-Alright. When people see you
on the street,
do they mistake you for
Jonathan Lipnicki from
"Jerry Maguire"
or Freddie Mercury?
-Ooh!
Um...I wear a mask
a lot lately, so --
-So people could think it's
Jonathan Lipnicki,
the child from "Jerry Maguire"?
-Yeah, yeah. So, who knows?
You know?
-I think that one busted him
wide open right there, Tariq.
We got him.
[ Drumroll ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I think there is
a 'stache under that mask.
Sharif, you want to let us
see what's happening?
-Is there a 'stache under
that mask?!
[ Drumroll ]
-Yeah!
♪♪
Yeah!
He's got a mustache.
It looks good, right?
-Yeah, it looks good, right?
-You look good, yeah.
-Thank you, thank you.
-Thank you for playing.
You've won this
Bluetooth-enabled smart mask.
Thank you for playing.
What is this?
This has been "Is There
a 'Stache Under That Mask?"
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show."
Thank you very much.
-Thank you very much.